all right let's talk about alpha star
Grandmaster level and Starcraft 2 using
multi-agent reinforcement learning the
corresponding paper looks like this and
is by oral VIN yells at al from deep
mind and has been published in the
journal of nature recently now let me
say this first stop publishing in nature
this is a journal is not open access it
makes its readers pay for getting the
article so actually you can access this
article or a public version of it for
free but you can't print it you can't
download it unless you pay for it and
this to me it seems it seems ridiculous
because none of this money goes to the
authors of the article none of this
money goes to the reviewers the review
quality isn't notably better at least in
the field of computer science all of
this is is a publicity stunt by deepmind
because Nature has been kind of
impactful in the last decades it's like
guru look at me
I got a big dick I published in nature
not not nothing more than that it's like
open a I saying their model is too
dangerous to release to the world I
guess deep mind might make the same
claim about alpha star it's like too
dangerous of a Starcraft player yeah so
ah stop stop this publish your research
in open access nature or journals like
these for computer science it's a
remnant of the last century so come on
and join everyone else in in
distributing knowledge all right rant
over let's jump in into this article so
that the article describes how to train
a reinforcement learning agent to play
the game of Starcraft 2 so Starcraft 2
is this game for everyone who doesn't
know just very quickly explain the game
Starcraft 2 is a real-time strategy game
and you're kind of in this top
third-person view and you control your
units and the goal is kind of do move
your units around and first of all build
up buildings
and using those buildings you can then
produce more and more diverse units and
ultimately you want to kind of produce
some sort of army that can go to the
opponent and destroy the opponent's base
so you control all of this on a computer
using a mouse and the keyboard and
Starcraft is notable for being very
balanced so there are three different
races you can play so first are the
Terran which are kind of human human ish
they have marines and tanks and
helicopters I believe in things like
this then the Protoss are some sort of
alien race that are super advanced so
they can teleport and have energy
shields and things like that and then
the last or the Zerg and the Zerg
are kind of a key ground dwelling
creatures that infect things and spread
like you know like a disease so the the
interesting thing here is compared to
other realtime strategy games is that
the three races they play very different
so they they have the game is almost a
different game if you play as a
different race but they're so well
balanced at almost any matchup is kind
of a a fair game between equally skilled
players so that's that's mixed Starcraft
pretty unique also pretty unique is the
very very high action per minute rate
that pro players get like their it play
this insanely fast
so again lasts about 10 to 15 minutes
and as I said the goal is to destroy the
enemy base all right so to Train RL
agent to play this is very hard because
like the action space is very high you
have to target with your mouths part of
the screen right you have to look what
is on the screen what can I do right
there's this mini-map down here there
are things you could do their opponents
you can target and so on so all of this
is very very very difficult for an RL
agent
and at the end right after whatever ten
minutes ready play play play play play
and after 10 minutes you either win or
you lose and can the RL agent has to
figure out which of the actions that I
did during those 10 minutes right is
well this one was this one which led to
me winning or losing these are very hard
problems for reinforcement learning and
the deep mind has combined almost every
trick in the book known so far to RL to
achieve this now the main the main
contribution I'd say here that is novel
is what is called League training and
we'll get to that so first of all if you
don't know what reinforcement learning
is reinforcement learning is basically
what I just described you have an input
right which is could be this thing here
and you have a set of actions all right
you have a set of actions that you can
do which the set of actions here is
anywhere you can click right you can
click anywhere on the screen and you
have to do this over and over and over
and over again until you either win or
you lose and from that you will see you
will at the end receive yeah you win or
you lose and then you have to kind of
learn to play the game so it's machine
learning hardcore because you get
minimal information and have to achieve
a lot of things from it so the first
thing that deep mind actually does is it
does supervised learning and we'll get
into how exactly the the model works
later but first thing deep mind does is
it trains an agent to simply imitate
humans right so you have human data and
from the human data you so these are
games played by humans good humans right
no not people like me so these these are
games played with humans from a
significantly high yellow and the first
thing you extract is this Z here
z is a called a statistics vector and as
I understand it it's mainly the build
order which means in which order do you
build your buildings and units and this
is very important in StarCraft this is a
strategic decision where you say ok
first I'm going to build three worker
units this is like three workers worker
worker worker and then I'm going to
build a house and then I'm going to and
so on so these are major strategic
decisions that that you kind of have to
make with minutes minutes ahead of time
to plan in advance and this this is kind
of a stays constant for the game so this
is extracted and provided to the model
as an input so what is the current
strategy basically the current overall
strategy the second thing that is
extracted is this is at every time step
the observation that the humans had so
the screen that humans see and also the
actions that the human did write so the
human takes its mouse and click
somewhere right this is supposed to be a
mouse pointer and clicks here right and
then the model this part here this is
the model and this is the policy
function of the model so the policy
decides what to do right is trained to
match the action that the human did so
in essence first you train an agent to
simply imitate humans and this you can
do by supervised learning right this is
classic machine learning each each step
you have on this input which is an image
and you have the strategy or trying to
follow and from these two you're simply
trying to match that action that human
did assuming the human made a good
decision so this is how you initialize
right is you don't start from scratch
now I have to say that even though this
name is alpha star it has surprisingly
little to do with alpha go or alpha
zero that deepmind has done before
mainly this is entirely model free
reinforcement learning and and and goes
more into the direction of yeah classic
classic deep RL and you can see with the
human data you can already get pretty
far so these down here are the league's
of starcraft and this this here are
percentiles of players and you see with
the supervised training you can get
almost you can get better than eighty
eighty five percent of human players
already right so pretty pretty
impressive already simply by imitating
humans now so the the the way to eat to
further improve this and let's actually
go first into how the model looks like
so down here they describe this model
that's it so the model is supposed to
map from input to output so from the
screen that the agency's right and some
other things to what the agents going to
do to an action a if you simply do this
at every time step then you have a game
playing agent so first the question is
of course how does this happen
now the input isn't only the thing that
the agencies which is this the mini-map
and the yet the mini-map I believe
that's the mini-map or the entire map
well it it's in essence it is a picture
it is also a list of entities so the the
game engine extracts a list of entities
and this can be inside the screen here
and outside the screen for friendly so
they it's the assumption is the agent
knows about all of its units and where
they are and what their statistics are
so in this entities
thing for each entity you have a list of
what is its health
what is its type what is its position
does it carry any items and so on all
the things you need to know about this
entity and this is in this list of
entities and along with that also
opponent entities but only the ones that
are on screen all right so all of this
goes into this list of entities and then
the next features are scalar features
and as I understand it scalar features
are things like what race are you
playing currently what time is it in the
game and so on so these are additional
features and also baseline features and
this this is mainly use to train the the
value network and if you this is not
going to make sense if you know nothing
about reinforcement learning but one
main contribution of this paper is or
not contribution or but kind of think
that they claim is that for computing
the value network they also use the
observations so all of this for of the
opponent player because you know this
during training because you're doing
self play and you don't need these value
network during inference you can
actually do this and this improves
performance significantly all right so
that's just for people who know RL very
well everyone else don't don't worry too
much about these things all right so
this these are the inputs these scale
features the entity and the mini-map
they Co each one goes through separate
encoders so the mini-map goes through a
ResNet which is a convolutional network
and the entities go through a
transformer which is kind of a thing too
it's appropriate to encode a set of
entities right scalar features go
through a classic feed-forward network
MLP all of these get combined here into
a deep lsdm that goes over time now the
deep LS TM is what really makes the
strategy because each time step
each time step a screen like this is
input into the into the thing but but
the agent also needs to remember what
did it do
last steps two steps ago right this is
important because you don't have full
observability you need to know what did
I do in the in the past and that's where
the so if the last step you saw this
screen and that step before you saw this
screen right then all of this would go
through this encoding step into the lsdm
right so the LS TM will encode now over
time all of these different steps and so
you can kind of say alright if I have
just started building a building I
should probably not build the same
building again even though I can't see
it on the screen right because I know
that three steps ago I did start
building a bill build a building yeah so
this is kind of the the LS TM is
basically where you integrate your
strategy over time so from the LS TM you
have to make two predictions you have to
make a prediction of what to do this is
the action and how valuable or is your
current state and how valuable is your
current States this is called the value
network usually this is a core component
of deep reinforcement learning these two
components one is called the policy
which would be everything over here and
what is called the value network which
is called everything over here these are
the things you need to do actor critic
learning and actor critic learning is
the current state of the art in deep RL
so deep mind does nothing else here
except as I said they use these baseline
features for the value network but if
you don't know what a value network is
don't worry about it the important part
for playing the game is actually the
part over here the called the policy so
first you need to do to decide what
action you do and that there are many
action types in StarCraft as already
said you can build a building you can
move a unit you can actually move the
camera that's an action type right
because you want to maybe see what's
over here or over here
over here so that's an action you can do
and you if you have decided on what
action you want to do you have to decide
when do I do it so you see the action
type once you figure it out it goes into
the next neural network and that decides
ok when do I do it
when do I do this action so it specifies
a delay then once you've decided what to
do and when to do it it goes into the
next neural network and that decides
should I put this into the queue of
actions because the agent here is
limited to a certain number of actions
per second and I think it's 22 actions
per five-second or something like this
so in order to mimic you know human
limitations so the that there's a queue
of actions to be executed and the agent
needs to decide do I really want is this
action so important to put it into the
queue all right if you have decided what
to do when to do it
well whether you would like to do it at
all all right then you have to you have
to say it goes into the next neural
network and you have to say all right
which units do I want to do it with
right if you want to build a building
you can have to choose one or many
workers to do it I don't actually know
how Starcraft works in this I'm bit of a
noob but you have to you have to select
the units with which to do the action
for most of the thing and there I like
the use of a pointer Network here so
what a pointer network is is a network
that can point to its own input it's
sort of like an attention network but
not really in a pointer network if you
have a set of inputs like we have here
so entity entity entity entity entity
write all these entities and you can see
the the entity embedding the entity
encoder actually has skip connections
that go here right so this network
directly gets these these entities as
input it can then write to you then you
have a neural network on top
that neural network that general that
work takes all of these things as an
input and what the neural network will
output is a pointer to one of these
things right I can say look I point to
this thing right here this is a called a
pointer network and yeah as I said it's
different from an attention Network
which might so an attention network is
where you get a distribution actually
you get a distribution in both cases
there is a difference but wait we don't
have to really time to go into it here
but in essence with a pointer network
you can select which of these entities
you want to do something with all right
now you've decided on which action when
whether to queue it with which you need
to do it now you have to decide for some
actions for example if the action is
attack or heal or something this target
unit which unit do you want to target or
which which location on the map you want
to target this is the target point here
and you can see again here are skip
connections from the entity encoder and
from the spatial encoder to these things
and while the target unit is an
attention network as this like a much
like a pointer network II will kind of
point to places in lists the target
point is a D convolutional ResNet what
that means is so you have this spatial
encoder here will embed the mini-map so
there will be a neural network right
here actually let's draw the neural
network in this color right here it will
give you a an embedding of that right
and that's what you what you feed into
that's what you feed for example into
the LST M but then what you do is you
have a D convolutional Network which
again produces a mini-map
but on this mini-map there this is not
it's not the original mini-map but it's
kind of a distribution of locations so
it said here here do I want to point all
right so the that this neural network is
responsible for producing this dot on
the mini-map basically saying okay I
know what to do when to do it with which
units to do it and so on I want to do it
right here on the mini-map okay and now
you have it right you go from the input
which are these things the mini-map the
entities and so on to what do I want to
do where when with which units and so on
all right this is called a policy and
it's extremely complicated
every one of these boxes here is a
neural network and you can see it is
very it's a lot to train and they of
course they have a lot of resources
since they are deep mind but that's the
the main thing all right
they have a few tricks to train this and
we won't go too much into this but one
of the tricks is V trace from the Impala
paper one of another trick is up go up
going policy update and a third trick as
TD lambda learning here and all of these
are kind of improvements onto classic
actor critic reinforcement learning
style like a to C or a three C if you
are interested then you can you know
look into these things so that's how
they train it and the question now is
what's the protocol for training it we
saw okay there is supervised learning
cool then there is reinforcement
learning all right but you can't just
apply and this is in reinforcement
learning this is what we said you get
kind of a reward and the
word goes into the steady lambda and V
tracin and upcoming policy update to
train the value function and the policy
but the special thing that this paper
introduces is what's called leak
training now in in papers like alpha go
or alpha zero what had been done is
called self play and self play basically
means you have an agent you have an
agent right you have this how in a row
an agent that's this is supposed to be
an artificial intelligence right how do
I make it artificial okay it has a
little hat right a funky hat it's a
robot and the robot will play a copy of
itself right and the copy it might be
slightly different but the it basically
these two these two play each other and
thereby become better and better and
better and you can see this like over
time as as the purple one gets better
the blue one gets better as well because
they kind of play against each other and
when one falls behind right one wall and
falls behind then they simply copy over
from the other one basically copy the
other one and then they catch up again
right they catch out right and they
continue competing so by competing
against each other they get better and
this is called self play now people have
noticed this kind of leads to
instabilities because you can get a kind
of trap get trapped in cycles like
rock-paper-scissor cycles so what they
do is they will actually as they get
better so this is the first version
right and the second version they are a
bit better now so they have bigger hats
right and you're bigger bigger larger
hats right and down here they are even
better so they have like ginormous hats
but they might have some weaknesses
because they only play against each
other right so this is the same players
but
over time what they will do is they will
actually play occasionally play old
versions of the other player or of
themselves right occasionally the new
versions will fall back and play old
versions or not only the current
versions of the agent or old versions of
themselves right so this this is called
fictitious self play in that you always
play the you know not only played at
your current kind of opponent or your
current self I mean it's the same anyway
because you keep copying the weights you
also play the old ones and this paper
goes a step further and says actually we
we do this but we want to prioritize the
good ones so for example we know that we
know that the current ones are good
right but we know that this particular
one was also pretty good so far so we
are we keep making we keep making these
these new ones play against this one
more often and this has led to kind of
an improvement in these kind of self
play algorithms and the the real new
part of this of a-star paper is the fact
that they do this League training and in
the league training they this this is
what it looks like but I find this
graphic rather confusing I'd rather
explain it like something like this all
right so there is your current your
current strategy and you have a hat
right and you do all of the you do all
of the all of the I play against myself
with the smaller hat thing right I play
against past versions of myself fine but
then you also do you have what's called
exploiters and exploiters an exploiter
is a let's call it a triangle hat
because it's very evil what it does is
it's specific
Klee targets only the current good agent
right so this this agent right here is
tasked with playing old versions of
itself and playing the exploiter both at
the same time but the exploiter is only
tasked with playing this thing so what
it can do is it can specialize in
exploiting whatever weaknesses this
player has of course the hope is that
the this player will become better in
response because there's a player trying
to exploit it right so every and as this
s this player becomes better than this
player here is reinitialized and tries
to find new weaknesses right so as this
as this one continues to learn so the
exploiters they are initialized you can
see this here so these are called the
main agents and you can see they play
against each other right one of them
they play against each other they play
against past versions of themselves so
these are past versions of themselves
but then there are these main exploiters
and the main exporters they're
constantly reinitialized from human data
right you can see this here their
reinitialized
and they only play against these main
players right they don't have to deal
with any of the past players or playing
against themselves stuff they only try
to exploit the main players and thereby
the main players get better once they
get better than an exploiter they are
reinitialized
so the exploiters are reinitialized to
find new exploits of their main agents
the third component is what's called a
league exploiter and a league exploiter
is the following so that league let's
the league exploiter here and it's hat
is a wavy hat and what the league
exploiter does is it plays against past
versions of itself and others so it does
play against the league exploiter sorry
with smaller wavy hat it also plays
against this thing by the way the this
this year also plays against past
versions of this and of everything else
you can see here the past version arrows
it goes against all past players so this
this represents all the past players
that ever existed and so does the so
does the so here but also against past
versions of this of this main exploiter
here but the important thing is that
current main exploiter doesn't play in
past versions of its of itself right so
this also plays this and this place this
and this place this and this also plays
this so the league exploiter they do
take part in this whole league business
like playing against past versions of
all the players but it only plays
against the main expensed the main
exploiters and this is a thing that i
find missing here
honestly I don't know if I don't
understand this but I'm pretty sure I do
like these also play these and that's an
arrow missing in the in the drawing the
league exploiters play the main agents
but the main difference between the
league exploiters and the main agencies
the league exploiters they don't play
themselves right there is no there's no
playing themselves on the league
exploiters so the league exploiters what
they can do is they can find weaknesses
of the entire league and kind of terrain
terrain the by playing against the main
opponents using those found weaknesses
you bet that the main X the main agents
will get better against those major
weaknesses of the entire league right so
the main agents first of all they get
better by playing the main exploiters
because the main exploiters are mainly
trying to exploit the main agents the
main agents also get better by playing
the league exploiters because the league
exploit
find weaknesses of the entire league
right so and the main agents they also
get better by playing each other so that
makes these these main agents kind of
you can say they're trained against
everything under the Sun right against
any possible exploit that can be found
either in selves or generally and
thereby they get really good at
Starcraft because they can counter
pretty much everything so this is how
League training works and this is what I
feel is the main contribution of this
paper to the reinforcement learning
world now they do an ablation study here
you can see where where where this ends
up so these final agents here they end
up in Grand Master level Starcraft and
beat 99 point some percent of human
players so really really good they do an
ablation study of all of the tricks they
use so this is pretty much all tricks
they use and you can see here this
includes this league composition right
what what happens if we only have main
agents then main exploiters League
exploiters and you can see the elo going
up then you can see okay
multi agent learning how much does this
fictitious self play the fact that we
prioritize to strong players and so on
how much does this help and you again
see the elo going up how much does it
help that we use human data how much
does it use that we help that we use
these different networks and so on they
have very a very good kind of ablation
studies of how much each of the each of
the things helped here they investigate
what if we didn't have a camera
interface so what if we could see the
entire game at once and not only kind of
the
opponents that are within the camera and
what if we didn't need to move the
camera they investigate the off policy
Learning Corrections that we mentioned
and so on so I find this very cool that
they do these huge ablation studies to
show really how much each of these
tricks that they used helps in
generating their superior performance
and here you can see how these um agents
develop so over training and having to
have a massive infrastructure and they
trained for days you can see this here
but you can see that the the main agents
just get better and better and better
and better
while the main exploiters of course they
stay the same but they are they kind of
keep getting reinitialized right so this
main agent is trying to exploit these
these sorry these main explorers trying
to exploit these main agents this one is
trying to exploit these one they're not
by themselves really good agents but
they're simply trained to to find and
exploit weaknesses of the main agents
likewise these league explorers they do
get better with the league but they are
only concerned with exploiting current
and past versions of the league
right also to make the main agents
better so everything is geared towards
making these main agents better and you
can see it actually works they have some
analysis of which builds which which
units these agents build I'm not too
versed in starcraft to comment on this
but all in all I find this to be a very
cool paper and I I find it to be
described fairly clear what they do
though they do not release the source
code they release some kind of pseudo
code but the analysis and oblations are
very good
the results are let's say questionable
because of course the
of course the the you can't compare
machines to humans especially in a game
where you have to make quick actions
even if you limit the actions right they
did they do this here right so they have
kind of up this monitoring layer which
limits the actions and introduces delay
and so on but still like if if a is it's
not the same as a human who might not
always be able to do these 22 actions
per 5 seconds who if something quick
happens may need to have some kind of
relaxation phase and so on but they try
with these kind of delays and action
limits they try to model this this these
kind of limitations so that's um yeah
that's I find this as fair as possible
this is what I find kind of problematic
so they own units as I said the agent
can also see the ones that are outside
the camera and that seems kind of shady
because of course you can you can claim
humans can do whatever command groups to
also control units outside the camera
but it's not really the case so that's
that's sort of a distinct advantage that
the machine has but yeah in any case I
find it to be very well done and I hope
this made it a bit clearer what the
exact contributions are and with that
have fun time playing against alpha star
bye bye